When your eyes are sunken in like mine,
more people just assign you 5+ years.
When your nasal labia poles decide to fold in half,
like minded people assign you 10.
And when your neck lacksity drop,
forget about it. People are offering to walk you across the street.
How did I. Fifteen years of affliction that I didn't do is listen to these two.
We're trying to get you to buy this Calcium volume duo said
I was listening to hot 50 year olds,
average women with reviews and my almost 60 year old mother.
They said
if you wanna firm your creepy saggy skin from your head down to your neck,
gonna take this intense extra volume firming cream.
So they apply from their head down to their declate and go to bed with it.
You're gonna rub it in when you wake up in the morning.
Don't feel weird. If your skin feels almost hot in frozen light,
supposed to feel that way,
that means it's working. Pro tip
put it on your hands set. If you have smoke or straw lines that look like this,
you're gonna take the wrinkle smoothing balm stick
and put it around your mouth like this.
This is the Korean glow top in a quick that everybody is talking about.
It's because that rebornic in Calcium in it.
That's cynically woven to build back volume in your dermis
instead of your under eyes or nasal labia folds.
Look like minded, you're gonna Take that same rebornic and Calcium again.
Their Deep Intense facial patches.
Gonna put this wherever you have volume loss,
fine lines, wrinkles or darkness.
Most high end eye patches come with eight,
these come with 60. You're gonna use a core stick first,
then you're gonna put the eye patches.
Gonna put these in the fridge.
You're then gonna go to bed with them on.
They solidify. You're gonna wake up in the morning looking like a brand new twitch
If you have sandpaper texture or crater like pores like I used to have,
you're gonna skip the 700 dollar microneedling session
and you're gonna use Korean spicules instead.
Cause it's the not a lame thing,
you're just doing it at home.
I start rubbing this in thousands of tiny
microscopic needle like structures called spicules.
Causing micro damage to my skin's barrier.
Which is sending a rapid body response.
That texture stare and rejuvenation.
Just as reflective as a spa micro needling.
You have sun spots that look like this.
Once you open up those micro channels,
then gonna go in with their pigmentation chaser
10,000 ppms of that same reborn Calcium is gonna go in on a more cellular level
to break up those hard to reach melanin cluster.
Only tweaking your hyperpigmentation
but preventing more from forming.
And look at what that does to your skin.
One years. If you listen to these two and you only got these,
you're already slaying well over half of what This entire bundle lost.
My almost 60 year old mother is on her second order
because of this transformation.
It will have what my mother's having.
The problem is this is so hard to set.
It was complete at least fold out at the end of January and then February.
If you see that link pop up above my name,
go ahead and grab it
because you don't know how long this almost bait see relent off fail is gonna past
Or if they're even gonna be clocked.